las luces de Hollywood Fueron empañadas
por la niebla California vive días de
desconcierto luego que una inusual
tormenta de nieve que azota Estados
Unidos llegara a la costa del Pacífico y
obligar a las autoridades a lanzar una
alerta desde el viernes empezamos a
emitir una advertencia de ventisca una
de las primeras que hemos emitido en
décadas Esa es la naturaleza inusual de
este evento el extraño fenómeno invernal
ha generado severas consecuencias por
caso el río Santa Clara arrasó una parte
de la heladera en un parque y arrastró
casas rodantes mientras que ha
dificultado extremadamente las
condiciones de manejo sin embargo la
sorpresiva nieve también ha sido un gran
atractivo por algunos californianos vivo
donde no hay nieve la única nieve que
tuve fue granizo en primer grado y es
bastante emocionante hemos estado
construyendo muñecos de nieve y luego
rompiéndolos estuvimos paleando nieve
todo el día es muy divertido porque no
he estado en la nieve en mucho tiempo
pero para otros es una preocupación
seria
creo que una de las mayores
preocupaciones es que nos esperan
muy nieve la nieve se derretirá y nos
preocupan los corrimientos de tierra y
las inundaciones porque ya lo hemos
sufrido dos veces
el servicio meteorológico nacional
pronosticó fuertes vientos con
condiciones de ventisca y temperaturas
por debajo de la normal en el marco de
una tormenta que dejó a casi 85 mil
usuarios sin electricidad